[Musique]
en france quand on parle de transition
énergétique
on parle en général de transition
électrique c'est à dire que dans
l'esprit de l'essentiel du grand public
on est dans un débat nucléaire contre
éolien et solaire
alors c'est un débat hors climat et qui
moi ne m'intéresse pas ou plus
exactement que je considère comme étant
déjà réglé parce que quand on regarde le
dossier scientifique le nucléaire est
beaucoup moins risqué que les escaliers
la cigarette le hamburger et même les
gens qui se pendent parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à rembourser leurs dettes
donc c'est la question est
essentiellement ailleurs que dans le
remplacement du nucléaire par des
énergies renouvelables électriques et je
préfère de beaucoup parler de transition
climatique
quand on parle de transition climatique
on parle de quoi on parle d'un
engagement qui vient d'être pris par le
gouvernement français qui est de
supprimer la totalité des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre en france
or ce qui est absorbé par les puits
celui enrôler forêts d'ici à 2050
ça veut dire en pratique diviser les
émissions actuelles par set
on va dire et capturer le reste par les
forêts hors amélioration technologique
je dis bien hors amélioration
technologique ça revient à diviser par
sept la quantité de voitures a divisé
par sept la production de ciment la
production d'acier la production de
plastiques la production de mètres
carrés de logements
ça revient également à diviser par sept
la quantité de viande qu'on mange
bon donc on comprend bien qu'on n'est
pas en train de parler d' une bricole et
on est en train de parler de quelque
chose qui est tellement peu une bricole
que pour finir de répondre à la question
il n'y a pas l'ombre aujourd'hui une
stratégie sérieuse du pays pour nous
mettre sur ce genre de trajectoire
les 50% de nucléaire dans la production
électrique française sont à nouveau je
le répète un objectif hors climat c'est
pas un objectif qui concerne le climat
puisque le nucléaire ne fait pas
d'émissions de co2 même si beaucoup de
gens pensent l'un vers ce probablement à
cause des panaches de vapeur d'eau qu'on
voit au dessus des aéroréfrigérants
c'est un objectif que personnellement je
considère comme non pertinents c'est à
dire je pense qu'on perd notre temps à
essayer d'atteindre cet objectif alors
qu'on a des choses beaucoup plus
urgentes à faire par ailleurs c'est un
objet qui de diversion donc et pour
reprendre un parallèle que je fais
parfois si je vous coupe une jambe et
que je la remplace par une prothèse g
diversifier vos appuis
d'accord vous n'allez pas pour autant
trouver que votre situation s'est
améliorée
donc c'est un objectif qui n'est pas
pertinent de mon point de vue après la
question c'est est ce qu'on va finir par
y arriver
la réponse en dépensant quelques
milliers de milliards d'euros peut-être
est-ce que la situation derrière sera
meilleur nom et en particulier une chose
qui ne se sera pas améliorée
c'est qu'on n'aura pas diminué le nombre
de centrales tout simplement parce qu'un
jour sans vent et sans soleil on
entendra quand même faire monter les
ascenseurs avancer les métros allumer
des lumières faire fonctionner le
micro-ondes le grille pain et la machine
à laver donc et c'est très exactement ce
qu'ont fait les allemands
les allemands ont gardé le même nombre
de centrales qu'on est capable de
commander ce qu'on appelle les centrales
pilotable en augmentant très fortement
leurs éoliennes et leurs panneaux
solaires les espagnols ont fait
exactement pareil
donc si en france on met plein
d'éoliennes et de panneaux solaires on
gardera le même nombre de centrales ça
changera pas on baissera leur facteur de
charge
elles produiront moins du coup elles
gagneront moins d'argent or une centrale
nucléaire est un système à coût fixe
donc si ça gagne moins d'argent tout en
ayant les mêmes coups vous dégradez la
sûreté donc en fait c'est un truc de
shadocks ce qu'on est en train de faire
donc est-ce qu'on finira par y arriver
peut-être est-ce qu'on finira par y
arriver de manière indolore sûrement pas
aujourd'hui la croissance de l'éolien et
du solaire en france est une machine à
détruire de l'emploi
quand vous faites un kilowatt 1 mégawatt
heure pardon nucléaire en france vous
avez besoin d'importer un euro d'uranium
tout le reste c'est de la valeur ajoutée
française l'enrichissement se fait sur
le sol français
le cycle du combustible et sur le socle
le sol français pardon et quand vous
avez besoin de faire un mégawatt heure
solaire ou éolien le panneau est importé
de chine ou d'ailleurs et la nacelle de
l'éolienne est à portée du danemark
d'allemagne de chine ou d'ailleurs
donc vous importez pour environ 20 à 30
euros par mégawattheure de composants
donc vous augmentez les importations à
production constante et la macroéconomie
de base vous dites vous détruisez du pib
et donc de l'emploi
donc en fait quand vous augmentez et
l'éolien et le solaire en france ça
détruit plus d'emplois dans l'économie
nationale que ça n'en crée dans la
filière des énergies renouvelables c'est
la macroéconomie de base les énerve par
ailleurs ça ne change rien aux émissions
de co2 le les énergies renouvelables il
est intéressant de développer dans notre
pays c'est celle qui baissent les
émissions de co2 et qui par ailleurs de
ce même fait baisse les importations de
pétrole et de gaz
donc pour ça c'est quoi les énergies
renouvelables intéressante il ya la
pompe à chaleur pour remplacer les
chaudières à gaz et à fuel vous avez le
bois pour la boîte ou vêtements vous
avez les économies d'énergie qui sont
pas vraiment une source d'énergie
renouvelable mais qui sont des choses
qui peuvent être intéressantes notamment
dans le logement
vous avez le biogaz alors on n'en fera
pas
tout le gaz qu'on consomme en france
loin s'en faut mais on peut en faire un
peu de gaz renouvelables qui peut être
intéressant vous avez un peu d'agro
carburants qui sont possibles mais ça
rentre en compétition avec les cultures
qui servent à nourrir les hommes
si on sort de france c'est évident que
dans tous les pays qui ont des centrales
à charbon s'il vous remplacer une partie
du charbon part de l'éolien du solaire
est une bonne idée mais ça concerne pas
la france puisque nous on n'a pas de gaz
et de charbon dans l'électricité enfin
très peu alors l'innovation est souvent
quelque chose qui est invoquée comme la
baguette magique de harry potter pour
penser qu'on veut ça va résoudre tous
nos problèmes
on n'a pas arrêté d'innover depuis des
siècles et des millénaires et on n'a
jamais eu des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre aussi élevé dans le monde
donc l'idée que l'innovation et
autoporteuse pour régler les grands
problèmes planétaires et malheureusement
une illusion ça n'a jamais été le cas ça
ne sera jamais le cas ce qui règle les
problèmes c'est l'éthique la morale
appelez ça comme vous voulez c'est à
dire le fait que vous considérez que
c'est ça qu'il faut faire et pas autre
chose
et à ce moment l'innovation et
l'économie s'adapte mais tant qu'on dit
on innove pour l'innovation et puis
derrière ça finira bien par faire des
effets positifs qui nous intéresse on
est sûrs d'aller nulle part
[Musique]